we are hearing this morning from the
parents of 22 year old an american
bakari henderson is his name he was
beaten to death while on a trip abroad
this was back in 2017.
henderson was attacked by a mob outside
a bar in greece this attack was captured
on camera and i have to warn you here
this video is extremely extremely
upsetting
nine of the attackers seen here went on
trial in 2018.
six of them were found guilty of deadly
assault but none
none was convicted of murder a
prosecutor felt that the sentences were
too lenient and ordered a retrial
or the six convicted of assault and that
retrial is set to begin
later this month we first met bukhari's
parents that's jill and phil henderson
back in 2017
and now we are here in 2022 they say
that they are still fighting for justice
for the young man they call the
heartbeat of the family
why don't you first start us off by
telling us what the past five years have
been like um it's been a lot of highs
but mostly lows trying to process the
grief
and i would say the hardest thing has
been
feeling
like i'm not always doing the best that
i can by my other two children because i
spend so much time focused on
bukhari and the retrial and just trying
to keep his legacy alive because i miss
him so much think about him daily you
think about him daily oh yeah there's
something happens every day that makes
me think about him
phil and jill henderson's son bakari was
a world traveler in july 2017 the recent
college graduate was visiting greek
island of zakinthos when a night out
turned deadly the woman seen in this
surveillance video told authorities the
altercation began after she asked to
take a selfie with bakari
she says a serbian customer nearby then
said quote there are a lot of serbs in
the bar why are you talking to a black
guy
that man then hit bakari in the face
bakari hesitated struck back and then
tried to escape
a mob then chased him down the street
beating him against a car and then on
the ground less than 30 seconds later
bakari henderson was dead
his death made international
somebody headlines beaten to death over
a selfie it just makes no sense it's
very hard to to imagine that people
would have that much hate to do
something to another human being
in 2018 six of the nine suspects charged
with intentional homicide which carries
a life sentence in greece were found
guilty of a lesser assault charge
the attackers five serbian nationals and
a british man of serbian descent faced
between five and 15 years in prison the
other three men were acquitted
no one was found guilty of murder
at least four of the men have already
been released
you should not be able to chase a man
down and beat him to death and then not
go to jail and serve jail time
so that's all i have to say
take us through the first trial what
that experience was like for you
it was eye opening because it was so
different is the trial in english
no the trial is all in greek and even
though you can't understand what's being
said both of you still feel it's very
important for you to be there in person
yes why
um just so that they realize that bakari
is loved and
we are there to support the outcome of
this trial we want to see justice served
does the language barrier add to the
stress of the case oh yeah you can see
their body language
and their culture they're so animated
that you're not sure if they're arguing
and you're kind of you know tense and
stressed just trying to figure out okay
what's going wrong what are they talking
about during the first trial phil were
the defendants in the courtroom
uh yes they brought them in what was
that like for you to see the
men accused of taking your son's life it
was rough and the whole time i you know
looked like they were
there to have a good time just like he
was there to have a good time i just
kept saying to myself they only would
have got to know him they would have
loved him
if the only would have got to know him
they would have loved it
it was it was very hard because
they brought them in
and they have them sitting in the middle
of the courtroom in front of you
and
they never make eye contact with you
they never tried to even look to see
that we're even human during breaks they
would allow their family to come up and
like give them hugs and kisses and stuff
like that and i'm like
really you're doing that in front of us
and we'll never get to do that with our
son
it just felt like there was just no
real
respect for the fact that we were there
grieving
do you think the people of greece or the
public of greece understands what this
case is about
i think that the people of greece
overall
support
justice being served
because
greece views themselves as a country
that is very hospitable and built on
friendship
and so i think that they would prefer
that you know justice would be served so
that this black mark would be taken off
of the country as a whole you know when
i was in your home in austin
um
five years ago we went in bakari's room
what have you done with his room
we really haven't done much
we haven't even unpacked his suitcase
yet you have an unpractical suitcase
from greece
why jill
we just haven't been able to it just i
don't know
after he died you found a journal in his
room yes he actually had a few journals
and he had one with like all the
clothesline stuff and he had like his
designs he had what logo went where the
colors
the price points i mean everything in
another journal he had people he wanted
to meet books he wanted to read he had
songs he wanted to hear movies he wanted
to watch and he had um favorite quotes
from people who did he want to meet i'm
curious
um elon musk yeah he went to meet elon
musk elon musk it was a long
he had robert smith on there he had
actually tried to reach him in austin
to intern he wanted to intern for him
because he was a finance i think that's
a treasure to have yeah it is you've
also continued his work he was in greece
because he was shooting a photo shoot
for his fashion line correct
so that's what i spend all my time doing
what do you think he'd say about you
doing this
well he always told me i was going to be
working for him so we laugh now because
we are working for him full time next
week the hendersons will return to
greece for the fifth time
seven of the original nine men accused
in this brutal attack are being retried
for murder
are you more optimistic this time jill
i want to be
i'll say that i want to be i'm trying to
be it just was so devastating last time
to
have all that optimism and then
have it just kind of
thrown in your face at the last minute i
don't think they view
us black people the same as they do
white people over there and i felt that
in
the trial and the results of the trial
is that they treated treated and felt
like he was less than a man
i just truly hope that this time that
they really view bakari
as a child of god and the human that he
is and view him as somebody that could
be their brother their son their
grandson
their nephew their friend so
i mean i really want them to be able to
understand that when they're doing the
sentencing this time
boy gail yeah tony really tough to watch
that video all these years later
it is it is and you know jill has never
watched the video uh phil has watched it
because he really wants to try to
understand she can't bring herself to
watch it she says she she doesn't know
if she'll ever be able to do so but i
just think about this family who gets a
call from the embassy at three o'clock
in the morning and they look they don't
recognize the number and when they find
out it's the embassy they prayed before
they return the call because normally
you know it's not good news
but they certainly didn't think it would
be that and now they've devoted their
life
it's taken a financial toll on the
family an emotional toll on the family
and they're hoping maybe this time
they'll get justice you know we know the
names of natalie holloway we know the
names of gabby petito also terrible
stories and i just think people should
know the name bakari henderson because
the way this young man died and what he
represented
it just isn't it just isn't right i'm
all for a hashtag makari henderson i'm
hoping people will now say his name